la fraude fiscale simple pacte
républicain le nouveau scandale des
pandora paper en est une nouvelle
illustration après les luxes clic panama
peppers et tant d'autres tout va bien
dans mon tranquille puisque 48 heures
après ces révélations l'union européenne
supprime trois territoires de la liste
des territoires non coopératifs trois
paradis fiscaux de moi c'est vrai que
c'est un mauvais timing la france va
présider le conseil européen monsieur le
ministre quel mesure entendez vous
prendre pour lutter contre la fraude et
l'évasion fiscale alors que notre dette
flamber pendant que certains cachent des
millions dans les paradis fiscaux nos
étudiants font la queue devant les
banques alimentaires et nos agriculteurs
se débat dans des difficultés infernale
je vous remercie on vous répondre la
parole et au ministre délégué en charge
des comptes publics celle du shop la
parole
merci merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs destinateur madame
la sénatrice nathalie goulet quelques
mots d'abord pour revenir sur les
révélations d'un consortium de
journalistes 600 journalistes 117 pays
concernés et 12 millions de données qui
seraient exploités ou exploitable par ce
consortium des journalistes pour mettre
à jour des pratiques d'optimisation
d'évasion voire de fraude fiscale dans
un angle un grand nombre de pays et par
le biais de sociétés offshore à ce stade
et je vous être très clair sur ce point
les informations dont le gouvernement
dispose et à travers le gouvernement la
direction générale des finances
publiques selon les informations
révélées par la presse et comme à chaque
fois que c'est le cas en pareille
circonstance nous avons donné avec bono
maire des instructions extrêmement clair
la direction générale des finances
publiques consistant à exploiter
vérifier et analyser chacune des données
ans a dit sa disposition par ces
révélations médiatiques pour d'une part
vérifier si des contribuables français
sont concernés et le cas échéant
diligenter des contrôles fiscaux les
plus sévères qu'ils soient et les cas
les champs aussi en lien évidemment avec
le ministre à la justice les fonctions
les procédures judiciaires qui s'avérait
les plus utiles nous continuons à un
vrai contre la fraude fiscale à la fois
à l'échelle française à l'échelle
européenne nous avons permis l'adoption
d'une loi de lutte ont à freud en
octobre 2018 vous aviez pas active dans
ces débats
avec la création d'une politique fiscale
nous avons renforcé notre système
d'information avec notamment la
pérennisation de la rémunération des
aviseurs il nous développons
développement au niveau européen sans
lesquels nous poussons des échanges
d'informations extrêmement poussée
puisque pour 2019 ce sont 7 milliards
d'euros de revenus fiscaux
complémentaire à l'échelle de l'union
européenne qui ont été trouvés et dégagé
par des échanges d'informations portant
sur plus de 84 millions de comptes que
nous avons pu ainsi investiguer et
vérifier grâce à cette coopération il
aurait beaucoup à dire pour développer
les différents sujets les différentes
priorités que nous avons ce sont là les
premiers exemples je crois pouvoir
revenir à l'occasion de prochaines
questions sur ce que nous faisons aussi
en matière de lutte contre la fraude
fiscale mais je veux vous assurer de la
détermination la plus totale à lutter
contre cette fraude et à exploiter
l'ensemble des données auxquelles nous
aurons accès par les révélations vous
avez cités madame nathalie goulet ouais
mais c'est le ministre on est toujours
dans l'expo est votre bilan il n'est pas
exactement celui que vous dites parce
que vous avez réduit les moyens humains
pour le contrôle fiscal et douanier vous
avez démanteler la délégation nationale
à la lutte contre la fraude vous avez
perdu du temps pour la mise en place du
système de détection précoce de fraude à
la tva qui est un système thénac était
appliquée par tous les pays européens
dont on vous a demandé depuis plusieurs
années d'essayer de l'appliquer en
france qui vient seulement d'être
appliquée je rappelle que la fraude à la
tva c'est 5 milliards de fraudes
détectées l'année dernière et 10
milliards au niveau de l'europe le
gouvernement s'est opposé à l'amendement
du sénat qui visait à interdire les
aides qu'ovide aux entreprises disposant
de filiales dans les paradis fiscaux
préférant la circulaire allons savoir
pourquoi la circulaire c'est mieux que
la loi vous me le dirait peut-être il
reste 777 enquête préliminaire en cours
qui sont actuellement ouvertes pour des
affaires de fraude fiscale et de
blanchiment vous êtes opposé à la
position légitime du sénat qui a voté la
possibilité de prolongation de ses
enquêtes pour ces faits des liens que
vous vouliez réduire sans distinguo dans
la loi confiance justice et pour 577
enquête préliminaire il ya trois
enquêteurs je suis pas très sûr que
l'adéquation soit exact les chiffres
publié atteste de ce bilan désastreux le
résultat de la lutte contre la fraude a
été divisé par deux 17 et ces chiffres
sont ceux de votre ministère que vous
retrouverez dans l'excellent bouquin de
charles prat qui s'appelle le cartel des
fraudes 2 ou là on parle de fraude
fiscale monsieur le ministre le plf et
arrive et j'espère que nous pourrons
prendre des mesures vraiment efficace
que pour l'instant le compte n'y est pas
[Musique]